joining us now with reaction as
Anastasia tonello from the American
Immigration Lawyers Association
anastasiya I'm sure you disagree with a
lot of what I said there and I'll just
let I'll just let you comment well I as
I explained earlier a lot of the
comments are on the political climate on
economics I'll limit my comments to the
immigration laws and happy to discuss
the policies and how those are okay so
you're telling us what you won't talk
about but let's let's talk about why
there has been and I think we have a
graphic to illustrate this a tenfold
increase in the claims for asylum coming
out of these northern triangle countries
especially Honduras asylum requests
increased tenfold between 2009 and 2016
why do you think that is again I mean
there are issues in those countries
there's a lot of political unrest there
have been just traditionally there were
as a result of deportations a lot of the
prisoners that were in gangs in LA and
were deported have taken advantage of
political chaos in those countries and
were able to take advantage of systems
which leads to violence we see a lot of
these asylum seekers are women they are
children so a lot of them aren't I mean
a lot of them are women and children and
they're obviously incredibly sympathetic
and we want nothing but good things to
happen to all people who want a better
life for their families but the question
is under our current law and you're an
expert as an immigration lawyer I
actually did one immigration case when I
was a defense attorney believe it or not
but the asylum laws require a credible
fear of persecution yet in the surveys
that have been done of these migrants in
transit or when they're being deported
back home they overwhelmingly state that
their concern is an economic one and you
can't blame them you know that's hard to
make a life in Guatemala or El Salvador
I've spent a lot of time in both
countries and there
beautiful countries with rotten
governments but right now we have a
situation where we have hundreds of
thousands of cases backlogged in our
immigration courts and frankly we're all
out we're all out of personnel and we're
all out of money
as far as processing this so how would
you how would you balance those concerns
of the United States with our own
homeless problem our own you know
veterans on the streets problems our
opioid crisis the schools are being
overcrowded with the desires of
foreigners to come here for a better
life I mean I think earlier you were
talking about the the corruption in
Honduras and these demands put on these
officials and I think that what's in
what's incredibly important in all of
this is the rule of law is due process
where America the Constitution is very
strong we have very clear guidance and
rules on what what we are expects what
we expect to to give as far as legal
process and procedure so that is
something that I don't think we should
compromise on and I don't think we
should pick and choose who gets to
process that it's a fundamental part of
our of our carbone it's a fundamental
it's a fundamental concern for Americans
that we have borders that are actually
enforced and laws that are not gamed by
attorneys who go down to Mexico or go
down to Central America and literally
coach people as to how to make their
case and make their claim it goes from
representation to advocacy for policy
chains or advocacy for entrance into the
United States despite the fact that a
lot of these lawyers don't know much of
anything about the background of these
migrants I want to play a sound bite for
you from our homeland security secretary
about who else is trying to gain access
to America let's watch him order
security is national security and what
we see the Department of Homeland
Security receive 15 terrorists either
planning to travel or actually traveling
to the United States each day known as
suspected terrorists so that means
they're coming through our legal land
port and
and err are you concerned about that
that in these caravans I mean again
that's a drop of the bucket compared to
the thousands upon thousands of people
who have been processed into our country
since last October but it's a it's a
it's the visual image I think that gets
a lot of people but are you concerned
that in the mix of people both crossing
illegally and presenting themselves to
border officials that terrorists will
take advantage of this mass of humanity
I I believe that we should put that we
should have borders that applications
should be processed that people should
have their cases reviewed when they're
when they are presenting themselves for
entry to the United States but also
believe in smart borders I believe that
a lot of this information is
intelligence based that we have access
to information on who's traveling and
how they're coming in and so I think
that it takes only one person though
right in a stage it takes one person to
gain access to our country and we
already know about all the stories of
you know now Somalis some Somalis have
tried to I guess gain access to the
Caravan maybe exploit people within the
caravan which is also heartbreaking and
and so we know that game the system they
gamed it on 911 you know they've gamed
it before trying to come into our
country and plains it was shoes that
explode and if it's a porous border with
crushes of people coming at one time
that's the logical place for them to
enter and I know you're not a policy
maker but when we have lawyers rushin
down to Mexico to make the case for
asylum for people again that you know
you can't check the background on most
of these people most these people are
you know they're poor people with what
are gonna go to the like the local town
hall and in in Honduras and do a
background check on every client you're
not gonna be able to do that are you but
there are background cut there are
background checks and we do have very
smart intelligence capabilities so if
there are people on watch lists if
there's people that we're concerned
about not everyone's on a watch yeah
well not everyone's on a watch list but
I mean I understand your point and look
lawyers are lawyers are there to argue
the case for their clients and these
happen to be pro bono clients for all
these
migrants that are trying to cross the
border Anastasia we really appreciate
your coming on to explain your case and
your your perspective here a lot of the
lawyers down in Mexico are frankly not
interested in coming on to explain
themselves and you really advanced it
thank you so much